joe biden just wrapping up the speech
calling for the country to come together
as president trump recovers from the
coronavirus
he made a dramatic return to the white
house last night after spending
three days at walter reed medical center
the president tweeting
earlier that he's feeling great and
white house doctors announcing today
that trump is no longer reporting
symptoms
trump's comeback has reignited the feud
with joe biden over how
best to handle the virus the president
says we need to confront it
head-on don't let it dominate you
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines all
developed recently i know there's a risk
there's a danger but that's okay
and now i'm better but don't let it
dominate your lives get out there
be careful and joe biden claiming trump
is to blame
for getting infected look anybody who
contracts the virus
by essentially saying mass don't matter
social distancing doesn't matter i think
is
is is responsible for what happens to
them
because every major scientist and doctor
and immunologist
has said that's a very dangerous thing
to do
well first of all president trump didn't
say mass dope matter and social
distancing doesn't matter
um greg gutfeld what do you think about
the dueling
claims trump says don't let it dominate
you and joe biden says
if you know you got it and it's your
fault
well here's it's kind of like we're
always back to chapter one of the corona
story where we began was this prison of
two ideas either
you had to express fear in terror right
or you were
going to kill everybody but we've been
through all of that we've been through
this we've talked about it
we are distinctly american and that we
accept and access
accept risks and and and we've done this
i don't know since we came here the
explorers took risks coming here
so we know what can happen we see
that people are aware of of what they
need to do with masks and social
distancing
so this is a really old argument and the
only way biden can like
uh go after trump is to lie to say well
he said maths don't matter actually
fauci was the first person that said you
don't have to wear masks
remember that because he was fearful of
people hoarding it
but i think the big problem here is that
we keep going back to this
this prison of two ideas and we refuse
to acknowledge that you can be
in the middle take precautions and
express confidence about getting your
life back together
because if you don't do it you're going
to be like hyden biden you're never
going to want to remember this is the
guy who didn't want to take out bin
laden
this guy is somebody who doesn't like to
take any risks i mean
what does he want does he want us to
shut down forever because he certainly
isn't giving us any advice on the
economy is he
he doesn't want to take any risks yeah
juan to that point joe biden was against
reopening the economy he was initially
against reopening schools he was
initially against
opening up sports so to now say that he
has all the ideas to fix this thing that
doesn't make sense does it
uh i think you know i mean you know we
have 200
000 dead and what does that have to do
with the question
he's not really putting forth the plan
except i would shut things down again
excuse me excuse me jesse jesse you said
that he
favored keeping things in lockdown
longer than president trump and i'm
telling you
that right now we're not on a good path
right now the economy is stalled because
we are still
stuck with the corona virus and the
president of the united states himself
got sick
and this is
i would say oh yeah will you go look at
the unemployment rate you go look at it
yeah
it's going down it's been down they are
very high in other words you know what
we're all blessed
sitting here but there are a lot of
people who are out of work and
for you guys to ignore it i don't know
anyway
we're saying shut downs make it worse no
you guys want to distort but let me just
say this when it comes to this
argument about mass i just you know i
think to myself it's
bad policy to go around ripping off your
mask because you're back at the white
house right and say oh
what a man you know what the american
people overwhelmingly also
think it's bad politics they disagree
with it they think masks are a good
safety precaution and i think as for
trump to talk about how tough he
is what an insult to the family of
everyone who has gotten sick or
died in this country what a terrible
thing for the president to say about
america martha what do you think about
juan's
point what do you think martha about
juan's point
that i think what is it 70 percent of
the country supports mask wearing
and you know people see the president
coming back to the white house he takes
the masks off
it doesn't matter to me he's alone on a
balcony um
but you know the media hammers him for
the mask do you think that's bad
politics you know i i think the
president is a hundred percent
authentic he is who he is he's not
trying to come
off of this experience and reframe who
he is i think a lot of us thought
well he'll be you know in a different
mindset after this having been
you know sort of shaken a little bit by
getting it himself but you know we see
what his response is he comes back and
he says look you should be optimistic uh
you can overcome this i think he's
recognizing that we have
really great treatments that have been
put in place now that people can access
and take advantage of
i would just point out that you know the
polls show
that the president does not score very
well on this issue of covet and the
handling of covet i was looking at
pennsylvania polls uh plus 20 for joe
biden on the handling of coven so
you know it's not you know not looking
at my thinking about it or anyone else
is thinking about it i'm just looking at
some of the data that's out there
in these states now you know if these
polls prove to be wrong
they are mostly taken before the
president got back and i'll be very
looking forward to seeing how people
sort of absorb
his very optimistic outlook about this
and his encouraging words that people
can overcome this and go on
and whether or not it helps him we'll
see but he needs a game changer right
now
because he's having a tough time in a
lot of these polls across the country
all right dana perrino take us home
well i think you know the president um
didn't give a speech today like we heard
he might
but he did make some significant news as
he always does he puts his thumb
on the news of the day and that is that
he has decided
that he is going to end negotiations on
a coveted relief bill
because of the kovid's story also
includes obviously the economic story as
we alluded to earlier
nancy pelosi for the past several months
has been trying not to do a bill
one of the things she included in there
were things like ending voter id
laws legalizing ballot harvesting around
the country
and taxpayer-funded stimulus payments
for illegal immigrants
and more however i think that the
president
really could have helped himself by
pushing to get this bill done
because now if they go to the they're
going to go to the election with no
money for businesses
no money for restaurants no money for
schools nothing for the republican
senators to run on that really need this
going forward and nancy pelosi she
really kind of got what she wanted she
wanted permission to walk away and to
blame the president
and now she has that now perhaps this is
a negotiating tactic and he's all of a
sudden going to come out and say
okay fine i'll actually do something and
they can come to a number that they can
agree on
as long as she's willing to take out
some of those poison pills no it's 72
72 percent of americans agree with nancy
pelosi
on that 2 trillion dollar package and
trump is saying
don't pay attention to dealing with
coronaviruses economic fallout
pay attention to our supreme court judge
americans totally disagree bad
politics well they don't know what's in
that 2.9
package yeah that was probably the first
time they heard a lot of that went to
illegals one
yeah all right coming